every once in a while we like to do a
very official state of the podcast just
to make sure that the state of the
podcast is in fact strong uh what can
you tell us about the podcast how's it
uh it's
strong that's good okay
well i guess that's the end of the
segment good night we did it okay no uh
it's i think it's right and proper that
occasionally we check in and see
how we're doing how we feel about what
we're doing yeah because as i've said
before we sort of started this thing on
a whim
and it has grown and continues to grow
and i think
that to be responsible we should check
in and and think are we still sticking
with our core values right what this
podcast should be like a shareholder
call where we need to be accountable to
the listeners that we are doing our due
diligence yeah
yeah what are the core values this
podcast has values at all oh yeah much
less
i wrote out a very explicit almost
constitution for this show when it
started this podcast uh and it's all
about how all power flows from me oh oh
god you know
i'm sort of like the president and
congress
and
no no no it's a very intricate uh chart
that i worked out my biggest fear
is that success can corrupt
any enterprise
and the podcast has been you know i i i
like to be modest but it has been uh
quite successful and continues to grow
it is uh it's important to me that we
haven't changed in any way i became
at the risk of being a modest acclimated
to success oh god so many years ago
really in my teens
when i was part of a boy band um
doing it right oh
i was interested i'm trying to think if
i remember that yeah i wasn't doing it
right we came out of
it's true story
we're the only boy band to come out of
suburban boston and he's sure you're
doing right yeah you're doing it right
yeah when you're right a failed sitcom
pilot no no no we were doing it right
and uh it was me
and a bunch of other guys miles elliott
um and uh you couldn't remember the
other yeah the other guys weren't great
miles and elliot were terrific so you
were the justin timberlake oh i was
definitely the timberlake
and um we toured so
a lot of people don't know that i was
successful
long before you ever saw me online how
do people not know that if you were
successful well it's interesting we were
niche
niche success meetings
uh yeah we had uh we had four real
groupies people that followed us and
came and saw us perform so you were like
an indie boy band with cred that
wouldn't sell out to the limelight we
were an uh indie boy band with no cred
um
people and the reviews were atrocious
but uh we mostly
we played shopping malls um we did have
a couple of great songs uh we be who we
be was a good one
that's a pirate song yeah
we be who we be
by doing it for us yeah sex with me yes
please was one it's a question and an
answer featuring yoda sex with me yes
please
um and and we played along and you know
miles and elliot we the three of us were
in sync and then these other two
[ __ ] i don't remember their names
the point i was trying to make is long
before i was a writer or anything like
that or anyone knew me before i even
went to college when i was a teenager uh
i was in this band in hot years yeah and
we toured a little bit so i had some
acclaim anyway
i have been inured to getting a swelled
head i have i can't get a big ego just
because i your ego's so big it can't get
any bigger no that's not the point i'm
making it's just that i'm acclimated to
success now you two
um there's a danger there's a danger
that you would change and i have to say
in my opinion that is the biggest danger
to the podcast is that
gurley would start to
i don't know get a little full of
himself or that sona you would start to
think um oh wow you know this podcast is
nothing without me i'm really the one
that they tune in for and then the pro
it's probably true and then the problem
is then the whole thing can go awry
right so when we discuss the state of
the podcast to me that means
not yeah i know the numbers are great
and it's growing all the time and it's
you know whatever i guess some people
would refer to it as a sensation that's
not important there's no danger of your
head getting any bigger a sensation
that's i'm just reading whatever the
trade trade press uh but anyway and i
have to say i think the podcast is
strong because neither one of you has
changed right gorly you are still gourly
in all your girliness and sona you are
still uh loud belligerent um and
uh i think a part of that is i
had no idea anyone was listening to this
podcast
you know how i know people are listening
to it i know everywhere i go people
shout stuff from the podcast at me yeah
and um which is nice i like it the
funniest thing is they'll bring up stuff
from the interviews and
i won't remember what they're talking
about and often some of the things
you're just hearing might have been
recorded weeks if not months exactly
yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah so uh i
don't know i think you the because i
always am in awe of how grounded you are
even though you've had a lot of success
i know it it pains me to say this but i
think a lot of it is even though you get
like all this you know love and
adoration when you're out when you go
home you
you know your family is just like oh
it's it like lies like oh it's conan
yeah and your kids are like oh it's dad
it's like no one no one cares trust me
nothing nothing
nothing has saved me more from
nothing has saved my life more than me
total disinterest
and disdain i get
not just at my family at home but from
my family uh back in massachusetts you
know yeah yeah
they aren't having it they've never been
having no one cares they don't care no i
did a show the other night they went
really well and and my my wife and my
daughter came to it and um by the time i
got home it's like i never had done
anything yeah yeah i get in there like
you take the trash out
it literally is like did you put the did
you put the dog to make sure that he
peed
well but remember that show i just did
and the whole crowd was laughing and you
said i did it yeah yeah that was 20
minutes ago
did you put the almond milk away you
leave it out sometimes
put the [ __ ] almond milk away
and that's my daughter talking to me and
she's smoking a cigar oh my god i never
find myself on your side but that seems
borderline abusive yeah they're very
abusive people right but anyway i have
to say that uh
i am very fortunate
that we randomly all found each other
and started this uh podcast
and uh
it has been successful
but the nicest thing is that i i think
you guys are always the same you're
always going to be the same you will
never change for better or worse
you're trapped with the personalities
you've been given started off yeah and
then it went down but we knew that i
wish you'd just insult us straight away
no growth and we'll do the preamble no
evolution what's up and then i'm like oh
my god sincerity and then it doesn't
you're all joking aside you guys are the
best blah blah oh no it's not i'm just
reading what gourley just slipped me
now there's gonna be a piece of paper
you guys are the best i truly love both
of you and you're the reason the podcast
works
i donate my salary to your child's
college fund i donate my salary to your
child's college fund yeah and and my
kids well that's what i mitch children's
both what's the plural of child is it
children's why are you guys looking at
me the possessive plural i don't know
the children's television workshop but
that's possessive as well as plural
i find you're getting very possessive
right now with your knowledge of oh god
that was not good
i'm so sorry that was terrible we should
have gotten out minutes so where this
was going was so bad
you didn't let me finish i was going to
take it someplace brilliant but now
there isn't time let's hear it yeah no
no no we've got time it's
that's a weird thing to say to the
obamas
oh it's all for obama's including beau
the dog
seven obamas some obamas we haven't
heard of yet
oh yeah i can be there in a second 20
obama's possessive plural where does the
apostrophe go
[Music]
900 obama's incredible had no idea yes
i'll come to your hawaiian compound
right away
i'd love to be there one trump no not
interested oh what did you do that for
ah political no no we don't do that here
we can in that case i think we can sure
it would have been good to see where the
obama's rift went yeah we'll never know
now i was riveted i think we had this a
while ago this is so i don't know why we
didn't land this plane i'm just landing
it i'm landing it i just ding sully
sullenberger this no i'm going to do
better than that i'm putting it on a
tarmac
you know oh my god well i'm sorry the
guy landed it in a river
he had no choice yeah he's he's hundreds
of people if he had looked a little you
know what i'm sick of this all hail
sullivan
i agree if he had looked a little harder
yeah he'd have found a tarmac yeah
tarmac
yeah
oh my god no i'm sorry when i went to
piloting school they didn't say if you
put it in a river it's just as good and
we'll call you a hero precision
yeah didn't harrison ford land one on a
golf course once oh yeah sure what's his
way of playing golf
he has a golf ball strapped to the
landing gear and he has to put it right
in the hole
all right
what have we learned what have we
learned we have a great podcast
no one's personalities have changed
um the obamas call me regularly
uh and there are more of them than you
think and
and i think sullenberger gets too much
credit i'm sorry the state of the
podcast is strong